it was very good that
the leaders decided to devote time to
our collective response to the covet
pandemic first of all progress on
vaccines
is the key to a long-term solution to
this crisis
we're making good progress the
commission has already concluded
two advanced purchase agreements and it
is negotiating
five more and we are in discussions with
four more companies the second point is
the vaccine strategy
whom to vaccinate first the commission
has put forward a blueprint for vaccine
plan before the summer break and good
news is that it has been adopted now
with the health security committee we
discussed
that we must do a better job in
coordinating our assessment and the
measures
to be taken across member states weeks
ago we tabled a proposal for
accounts recommendations on this and i
urge the member states to find an
agreement on it now because
it increases transparency and clarity
for the european people
to know how to move on in different
regions of europe
the other topic are the council
conclusions
on the single market and the digital
first of all a well-functioning single
market is
crucial for us 60 million jobs depend on
it
second a competitive industry
industry provides 37 million jobs in the
european union and
two-thirds of our exports
and of course thirdly the need for
successful
digital transition discussions on how to
improve the functioning of the single
markets
have been ongoing for years the issues
are well known
two stand out in particular first of all
remaining barriers notably in the area
of services
and second problems with implementation
that deprive companies from the benefits
of a large
and deep market with regards to industry
the priority is to join forces in key
strategic areas
and ensure our industry can compete on a
global scale
as you know we presented our new
industry strategy in march to ensure
industry can lead
the twin green and digital transition it
will be an opportunity to take stock
of where we are with industrial
alliances for key technologies
such as batteries microelectronics
or hydrogen and efforts to improve our
resilience
such as on raw materials finally on the
digital transition europe clearly needs
to up its game we must make this
europe's digital decade
there are three priorities the first one
is data
we need to play our strength in the area
of
industrial data the second pillar in the
digital decade
is artificial intelligence but it needs
rules to ensure proper use and oversight
and the third topic is the
infrastructure
proper data connections it's a question
of equal opportunity
we will push forward this digital decade
while investing 20 percent of next
generation eu
on the digital because it's about
europe's digital
sovereignty we have to work on that
thank you